Do you sometimes feel overwhelmed by all of your stuff? If so, you're not alone. In recent years, a thriving, decluttering industry has sprung up to help us all deal with our ever-accumulating piles of things. The stacks of books that don't fit on our shelves, our kids outgrown toys, our clothes that don't fit anymore, our overstuffed closets, and our garages that are so full of clutter that they no longer fit our cars. How does all of this clutter affect us?
你是否有时会因为拥有的东西太多而感到不知所措？如果是这样，你并不孤单。近年来，一个蓬勃发展的整理行业应运而生，旨在帮助我们所有人处理不断堆积的物品。那些书架上放不下的书、孩子们不再玩的玩具、不再合身的衣服、塞得满满当当的壁橱，以及堆满杂物以至于停不下车的车库。所有这些杂物是如何影响我们的呢？
In recent years, psychologists' research has begun to find that living and working in cluttered spaces causes stress and anxiety and can harm both our mental health and our productivity. So why do we accumulate so much stuff and why do we find it so hard to deal with it? Does everyone find clutter equally stressful or are some people happy living in spaces that might seem chaotic to others? What is clutter anyway? And how is living in clutter different from hoarding? Do men and women deal with clutter differently?
近年来，心理学家的研究开始发现，在杂乱的空间中生活和工作会导致压力和焦虑，并可能损害我们的心理健康和生产力。那么，为什么我们积累了这么多东西，又为什么觉得处理它们如此困难呢？每个人对杂乱的感受压力程度相同吗？还是有些人乐于生活在对他人而言显得混乱的空间里？到底什么是杂乱？生活在杂乱中与囤积症有什么区别？男性和女性处理杂乱的方式不同吗？
How does clutter affect relationships? And if you want to clear the clutter in your home, what's the best way to get started and to stick with it? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Joseph Ferrari, a professor of psychology and distinguished professor at DePaul University in Chicago. Dr. Ferrari studies the psychology of clutter, including why we accumulate it, how it affects our mental health, and the link between clutter and procrastination. He's also well known for his research on the causes and consequences of procrastination,
杂乱如何影响人际关系？如果你想清理家中的杂物，最好的开始方式和坚持下去的方法是什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是芝加哥德保罗大学的心理学教授、杰出教授约瑟夫·法拉利博士。法拉利博士研究杂乱的心理学，包括我们为什么会积累杂物、它如何影响我们的心理健康，以及杂乱与拖延症之间的联系。他还以研究拖延症的成因和后果而闻名，
and is the author of several books on that subject for researchers, clinicians, and the general public. He has published more than 400 scholarly articles and is a fellow in six professional organizations, including APA. In addition to his work as a psychology professor, Dr. Ferrari is also a permanent deacon in the Catholic Diocese of Joliet, Illinois. Thank you for joining me, Dr. Ferrari. Well, first of all, thank you. As I heard your introduction, it touched on a number of topics that I can begin to jump in and share with you if you'd like, such as the difference between clutter and hoarding. They're not the same. As you know, hoarding is a psychological disorder.
并且是该领域多本面向研究人员、临床医生和大众的著作的作者。他发表了400多篇学术文章，是包括美国心理学会在内的六个专业组织的成员。除了担任心理学教授外，法拉利博士还是伊利诺伊州乔利埃特天主教教区的终身执事。感谢您加入我的节目，法拉利博士。首先，谢谢你。当我听到你的介绍时，它触及了许多我可以开始深入探讨并与你分享的话题，比如杂乱和囤积之间的区别。它们并不相同。如你所知，囤积症是一种心理障碍。
And the way I conceptualize this, and one of the ways to look at this is think of hoarding as lots of the same stuff. Toilipaper, toilet paper, toilet paper, toilet paper. And clutter is breath. So one is vertical and one is horizontal, if you would. So the person with clutter has lots of stuff. One of the other issues that you mentioned was, is it more common among one gender or the other? All right, let me answer that by sharing some of the background. In though, maybe a little over a decade ago, Dr. Catherine Roster from the University of New Mexico,
我对此的构思方式，以及看待这个问题的一种方法是，把囤积想象成大量相同的东西。卫生纸、卫生纸、卫生纸、卫生纸。而杂乱则是广度。所以，如果可以这样说的话，一个是纵向的，一个是横向的。因此，杂乱的人拥有很多东西。你提到的另一个问题是，这种情况在某种性别中是否更常见？好吧，让我通过分享一些背景来回答这个问题。大约十多年前，新墨西哥大学的凯瑟琳·罗斯特博士，
and I were at a conference and annual meeting for the members of ICD. And so I'd like your listeners to reach out to your local ICD member. That stands for the Institute for Challenging Disorganization. They're the professional declutterers. They're the coaches that you would hire if you have a clutter issue. They are the experts. Now, notice their organization. It doesn't say the word clutter because for them it's all an issue of disorganization.
当时我们正在参加ICD成员的年度会议。所以我希望你的听众能联系当地的ICD成员。这代表“挑战性无序研究所”。他们是专业的整理师。如果你有杂乱问题，他们就是你会雇佣的教练。他们是专家。现在，注意他们的组织名称。它没有提到“杂乱”这个词，因为对他们来说，这完全是一个无序的问题。
And I'll explore more of that in a moment. moment. But anyway, Roster and I were there. I presented on procrastination. They wanted to know more. And afterwards, Catherine Roster comes to me and says, let's collaborate. And I said, great, I want to study the psychological home. That's another area. I'm a social community psychologist for listeners who are familiar. And I'm interested in what is the meaning of home for people? We travel. We can't wait to go home. You eat me out of house and home. Home is something different than a dwelling. And she said, sure, let's look at that. Well, anyway, we collected our first study that came out in 2016 in the Journal of Environmental Psychology, and that data had about 1,600, 1,600 adults,
我稍后会详细探讨这一点。总之，罗斯特和我当时在那里。我发表了关于拖延症的演讲。他们想了解更多。之后，凯瑟琳·罗斯特找到我说，让我们合作吧。我说，太好了，我想研究“心理家园”。这是另一个领域。对于熟悉的听众来说，我是社会社区心理学家。我对“家”对人们意味着什么很感兴趣。我们旅行，我们迫不及待地想回家。你吃光了我的家当。家不仅仅是一个住所。她说，当然，让我们看看这个。总之，我们收集了第一项研究数据，该研究于2016年发表在《环境心理学杂志》上，数据涵盖了大约1600名成年人，
but only 50 men. And so the first thing I did is I contacted the ICD people and said, wait a minute, is this skewed? Is there a gender difference? And they said, no, no, no, no. men have clutter, but they don't see it as clutter. For men, it's my toys. It's my stuff. For women, our culture, tells them you've got clutter. So that's very interesting. So the experts will tell you there is no gender difference,
但其中只有50名男性。所以我做的第一件事是联系ICD的人，说，等一下，这有偏差吗？有性别差异吗？他们说，不，不，不，不。男性也有杂乱，但他们不认为那是杂乱。对男性来说，那是“我的玩具”。那是“我的东西”。对女性来说，我们的文化告诉她们“你有杂乱”。所以这非常有趣。因此，专家会告诉你，不存在性别差异，
even though one may go seek assistance and the other one doesn't. So when does clutter become a problem for people? Why do some people find it stressful and other people can live in the middle of it and they're fine? Yep, yep. There's a tip and point, like so many things in the way. life. It's when does it become procrastination and not just delay? You know, there's a point when things switch over from one to the other. The way Catherine Roster and I define a clutter based on our 2016 paper is it's an overabundance of possessions that collectively can create chaos and disorderly
尽管一个人可能会寻求帮助，而另一个人不会。那么，杂乱何时会成为人们的问题？为什么有些人觉得它很有压力，而另一些人却能生活在其中并安然无恙？是的，是的。就像生活中的许多事情一样，有一个临界点。什么时候它变成了拖延，而不仅仅是延迟？你知道，当事情从一种状态转变为另一种状态时，有一个临界点。凯瑟琳·罗斯特和我根据我们2016年的论文对杂乱的定义是：它是过剩的财产，共同创造了混乱和无序的
living spaces. That's a mouthful. I'm reading to you a definition. All right. But this may answer your question. Overabundance. There's just too much. You mentioned a moment ago. I'm a Catholic clergy. I am a deacon. And if I may for the moment, we're not called to live as paupers. Christ never tells you that to do that. He said the problem isn't abundance. It's attachment to the abundance. That's the problem. We don't let go. So we have this overabundance of things. And it really creates a chaotic life. and disorderly living. So from this, Roster and I have identified four areas where we look at clutter when we do these studies. Livability of the space. Does the amount of stuff you have impact your livability? You can't manage the physical space. Does it cause you distress? Is there emotional
生活空间。这很拗口。我是在给你读定义。好吧。但这可能回答了你的问题。过剩。就是太多了。你刚才提到，我是天主教神职人员。我是一名执事。如果可以的话，我们并不被要求像乞丐一样生活。基督从未告诉你要那样做。他说问题不在于丰裕。而在于对丰裕的依恋。那才是问题所在。我们不放手。所以我们拥有过剩的东西。它确实创造了一个混乱的生活和无序的居住环境。因此，基于此，罗斯特和我确定了我们在进行这些研究时观察杂乱的四个领域。空间的宜居性。你拥有的东西的数量是否影响了你的宜居性？你无法管理物理空间。它是否导致了你的痛苦？是否有情感
consequences from this? By having it, is there too much? And it really distresses your life. Okay, readers and listeners and readers of my work will find that we found that there's a negative correlation between life satisfaction and clutter. So the more clutter you have, the lower people report life satisfaction, great as, you know, great as distress. So here we live in this consumer culture, but more and more, more, buy, by, by. Well, you're actually not living a good, complete life because you'll be less satisfied. A third area is it impacts relationships.
后果？拥有它是否太多了？它是否真的困扰了你的生活？好吧，读者、听众和我的作品读者会发现，我们发现生活满意度与杂乱之间存在负相关。所以你拥有的杂乱越多，人们报告的生活满意度就越低，痛苦感就越强。所以我们生活在这种消费文化中，但越来越多，更多，买，买，买。好吧，你实际上并没有过上美好、完整的生活，因为你会更不满足。第三个领域是它影响人际关系。
We'll talk about in a few minutes. Why is it so hard to get rid of things? Because often we're not the only owner. There's often someone else. So it impacts relationships. Causes lots of stress. And of course, financial well-being. There's a study that was done that showed Americans have over $7,000 of unused stuff in their house.
我们几分钟后再谈。为什么摆脱东西这么难？因为通常我们不是唯一的拥有者。通常还有别人。所以它影响人际关系。导致很多压力。当然，还有财务状况。有一项研究表明，美国人房子里有超过7000美元的闲置物品。
A lot. $7,000. And then we wonder why people are a paycheck away. from, you know, being on the streets. Why credit cards are maxed out. Did you need $7,000 worth of stuff? And then I know you want to ask a question, but one more thing for the listener,
很多。7000美元。然后我们想知道为什么人们离流落街头只差一张工资单。为什么信用卡刷爆了。你需要价值7000美元的东西吗？我知道你想问一个问题，但还有一件事要告诉听众，
the three areas that ICD members, and we found that people have the most clutter is in the kitchen, in the closet, and books. So let me ask you this. Where does the propensity to clutter come from? Is it something that emerges in childhood, or do you become a clutterer as an adult? And is it learned so that if you had parents who maybe were tolerant of stuff or were cluttery themselves, does that make you a clutterer or not?
ICD成员发现人们杂乱最多的三个地方是厨房、壁橱和书。那么让我问你这个。杂乱的倾向从何而来？它是童年时期出现的，还是成年后才变得杂乱？它是习得的吗？如果你的父母可能对杂乱很宽容，或者他们自己就很杂乱，这会让你变得杂乱吗？
You didn't say, and are you born a clutterer? No. We're psychologists here. And we know that 98%, at least I was always taught, of who you are comes from learning. You know, the 2% is this is the biological. But we turn so much today for the biological base of things. So there's no biology. behind clutter. At least nobody has published that. But the answer your question is, we don't know. You're talking to half the scholars in the field, all right? And knowing the other half, she doesn't look at it, we have to look at that topic. I'm hoping someone's listening and say, oh, there's my dissertation. Ah, there's my, you know, master's thesis. There's the honors thesis as an undergrad. Absolutely. Come join me at the Paul. We'll do some great research together. The point is we don't know the development. Where's it come from?
你没说，你是天生杂乱吗？不。我们是心理学家。我们知道，至少我一直被教导，你98%的特质来自学习。你知道，2%是生物学基础。但我们今天太关注事物的生物学基础了。所以杂乱背后没有生物学依据。至少没有人发表过相关研究。但回答你的问题，我们不知道。你正在和该领域一半的学者交谈，好吧？而了解另一半，她没有研究它，我们必须研究这个话题。我希望有人在听，并说，哦，那是我的博士论文。啊，那是我的硕士论文。那是本科生的荣誉论文。绝对的。来德保罗加入我吧。我们将一起做一些伟大的研究。重点是我们不知道它的发展。它从哪里来？
I mean, I'd love to look at minimalist, the complete opposite of the clutterer. Don't know. Don't have any data on that that we know of. There were people who, in the 70s who looked at snooping was the name of a book, where people would look at people's possessions, but never in the point of clutter. And again, I want people to understand, we're not talking hoarding. The TV show is called hoarders, right? All right. It's not called clutterers. It's different. And again, as the ICD people would say, if it doesn't impact your life, if you're happy with having all that stuff, okay, it's only when it impacts financially relationships like anything in life. You need to deal something with it.
我的意思是，我很想研究极简主义者，杂乱者的完全对立面。不知道。我们所知的没有任何相关数据。在70年代，有人研究过“窥探”，这是一本书的名字，人们会看别人的财产，但从未从杂乱的角度出发。再次强调，我希望人们明白，我们谈论的不是囤积。电视节目叫《囤积者》，对吧？好吧。它不叫《杂乱者》。它是不同的。再次强调，正如ICD的人所说，如果它不影响你的生活，如果你对拥有所有这些东西感到满意，好吧，只有当它在财务、人际关系等方面影响你时，就像生活中的任何事情一样。你需要处理它。
So why is it so hard for people to declutter? I mean, when you recognize that maybe it's taking over your life, but how do you get started? And I want to ask you about the whole Marie Condo note. that we should keep the things that give us joy, right? I mean, I know you have views around that. Why is it so hard to declutter? All right, let me give you a few reasons. One, the items could be emotionally stressful. Now, not only negatively, as you're probably thought by those words, but could be positive.
那么为什么人们清理杂乱这么难呢？我的意思是，当你意识到它可能正在接管你的生活时，你该如何开始？我想问你关于整个玛丽·近藤的观点，即我们应该保留那些给我们带来快乐的东西，对吧？我的意思是，我知道你对此有看法。为什么清理杂乱这么难？好吧，让我给你几个原因。第一，物品可能会带来情感压力。现在，不仅仅是负面的，正如你可能从这些词中想到的那样，它也可能是正面的。
That is to say, it could be a trigger. When I pick the item up, all right, it might bring me joy or happiness. Happiness, not joy. I may look at it and say, oh, I remember that good time we, add, I got to keep that. Or I pick it up and I say, oh, yes, that was a really tough time in my life. That was some relationship. And I want to avoid it. So it could be a trigger to something in the past. And that's one of the reasons it's harder to declutter because it brings back, either positive or negative emotions. Again, another line of research could be, well, when is it one or the other?
也就是说，它可能是一个触发点。当我拿起这个物品时，它可能会给我带来喜悦或快乐。快乐，不是喜悦。我可能会看着它说，哦，我记得我们度过的那段美好时光，我得留着它。或者我拿起它说，哦，是的，那是我生命中非常艰难的时期。那是一段关系。我想避免它。所以它可能是过去某件事的触发点。这就是清理杂乱更难的原因之一，因为它带回了正面或负面的情绪。同样，另一条研究路线可能是，好吧，什么时候是这种情况，什么时候是另一种情况？
How can we predict? That'd be great. Also, it's hard to declutter because there are, as I was said a few minutes ago, multiple users. Most of the time the decision to keep or get rid of something is not just my own. Perhaps you have a partner. Perhaps you're living with someone. Perhaps there's someone else, others in your life. And so you want to throw it away, but the other people say, no, we need to keep it. So it may not be your own decision and getting rid of it would cause a conflict. And then the three lacks, I call it the three lacks, lack of time, lack of resources, and lack of ability. lack of time. People say, yeah, this is great. They're listening to you today, us today, and they're saying, yeah, this is great, but, as I talk about in my book, problem procrastination, the but, however, fact, we are great excuse makers. I would, I'd love to do it, but I don't have time.
我们如何预测？那太棒了。此外，清理杂乱很难，因为正如我几分钟前所说，有多个使用者。大多数时候，保留或丢弃某物的决定不仅仅是我自己的。也许你有伴侣。也许你和某人住在一起。也许你生活中还有其他人。所以你想把它扔掉，但其他人说，不，我们需要留着它。所以这可能不是你自己的决定，摆脱它会导致冲突。然后是三个“缺乏”，我称之为三个缺乏：缺乏时间、缺乏资源和缺乏能力。缺乏时间。人们说，是的，这太棒了。他们今天在听你，听我们，他们说，是的，这太棒了，但是，正如我在我的书《拖延问题》中谈到的，但是，然而，事实上，我们是伟大的借口制造者。我很想做，但我没时间。
Well, that sparked a study by Roster and I during COVID. Now you're locked up. Now you can't go anywhere. Now you have the time. Do you declutter? So we went to the ICD experts. They're board of directors and stuff and did a focus group before we launched our study. And we said, what do you think? Our people, and they're saying, oh, yeah, our clients always said, I'd love to declutter more, but I can't. And now they're home and they're not. That that's an excuse.
好吧，这引发了罗斯特和我在新冠疫情期间的一项研究。现在你被锁在家里了。现在你哪儿也去不了。现在你有时间了。你清理杂乱了吗？所以我们去找了ICD专家。他们的董事会成员等等，在我们开展研究之前进行了一次焦点小组讨论。我们说，你们怎么看？人们，他们说，哦，是的，我们的客户总是说，我很想多清理一些，但我做不到。现在他们在家了，他们还是没做。那是一个借口。
That is yet another thing. Because now that we're forced to be home, we don't. Now, Roster and I collected data, and we have an article coming out in the Journal of Consumer Affairs should be coming out shortly. I know it's online already, where we find three types of people during COVID who, decluttered. There were some who found it was exciting and energetic and loved it. There were some who found it as, well, it's something I got to do, but I don't enjoy it. And then there was the other ones who just didn't declutter. And those last two groups were much higher than the small group
那是另一回事。因为现在我们被迫待在家里，我们还是不做。现在，罗斯特和我收集了数据，我们有一篇文章即将发表在《消费者事务杂志》上，应该很快就会出来。我知道它已经在网上了，我们发现新冠疫情期间有三种人清理了杂乱。有些人觉得这很令人兴奋、充满活力，并且很喜欢它。有些人觉得，好吧，这是我必须做的事情，但我不喜欢它。然后还有一些人根本没有清理。而后两组的人数远多于那一小部分
who enjoyed decluttering. So lack of time, a lack of resources. People will say, I'd love to get rid of it, but I don't know what to do with it. Where am I going to go with it? My kids don't want to China. I can't get rid of the old furniture and stuff like that. All right. Again, good excuse making. My God, there are so many sources out there that are dying for resources. In my area here in the Joliette dioces, there's an organization that will take your furniture and put it into home of a new, new family who may need it. I'm thinking of the ones we donated. There was a woman whose husband was abusive. She finally left him. They helped set up an apartment for the woman and her kids, and we donated some of our furniture as our kids have moved on.
喜欢清理杂乱的人。所以缺乏时间、缺乏资源。人们会说，我很想摆脱它，但我不知道该怎么处理它。我能把它带到哪里去？我的孩子们不想要这套瓷器。我无法摆脱旧家具之类的东西。好吧。同样，很好的借口。天哪，外面有那么多资源匮乏的地方。在我所在的乔利埃特教区，有一个组织会接收你的家具，并把它放进一个可能需要它的新家庭的家里。我想到我们捐赠的那些。有一位女士，她的丈夫有虐待行为。她终于离开了她。他们帮助为这位女士和她的孩子们布置了一个公寓，我们捐赠了一些家具，因为我们的孩子已经搬走了。
So your family doesn't want it. Other families may want it. Yes, exactly. You know, you've read in the paper somebody's houses burned down. A flood has hit over there. They don't want your China, your kids, but that family would love to have those dishes. So leave a legacy, as what I say in my ministry. Leave a legacy.
所以你的家人不想要它。其他家庭可能想要。是的，完全正确。你知道，你在报纸上读到某人的房子被烧毁了。洪水袭击了那里。他们不想要你的瓷器，你的孩子们，但那个家庭会很乐意拥有那些餐具。所以留下遗产，这就是我在我的事工中所说的。留下遗产。
Make a difference in other people's lives. It may not be your own families, but in others. Lack of time, lack of resources, and lack of ability. Many people say they don't know what to do. That's where the decluttering coaches come in. All right. They're not necessarily psychologists. They may not necessarily even have a master's degree, but they're just people who are trained.
在别人的生活中有所作为。可能不是你自己的家人，但在别人身上。缺乏时间、缺乏资源和缺乏能力。许多人说他们不知道该怎么办。这就是整理教练发挥作用的地方。好吧。他们不一定是心理学家。他们甚至不一定有硕士学位，但他们只是受过训练的人。
The ICD group does lots of certifications for people who know how to organize and declutter, which takes me to the quote you gave me. Touch it and keep it if it gives you joy. Well, I struggle with that quote. Let's look at the data. You know, we're scientists here. All right? Consumer psychologists, as Roster has taught me, will tell you, if you touch something in the store, you're more likely to buy it. You're more likely to keep it. And that is the reason why retailers, companies in stores, will put things eye level for you so that you can see it and you can buy it. They pay extra to be eye level than to be lower or higher. All right. So they want you to touch the item. If you touch it, you're more likely to buy it. So you're more likely to keep it. The decodoring coaches would say to you, don't run out and buy a bin and start throwing stuff in the bin.
ICD小组为那些知道如何组织和清理杂乱的人提供了很多认证，这让我想到了你给我的那句话。触摸它，如果它给你带来快乐就留着它。好吧，我对此话感到挣扎。让我们看看数据。你知道，我们是科学家。好吧？正如罗斯特教我的那样，消费者心理学家会告诉你，如果你在商店里触摸某样东西，你更有可能购买它。你更有可能保留它。这就是零售商、商店里的公司会把东西放在你视线水平的原因，这样你就能看到它，你就能买它。他们支付额外的费用来保持在视线水平，而不是更低或更高。好吧。所以他们想让你触摸这个物品。如果你触摸它，你更有可能购买它。所以你更有可能保留它。整理教练会告诉你，不要跑出去买个箱子，然后开始把东西扔进箱子里。
Organize. That's why they're called. The Institute for Challenging Disorganization. Organize. And look and see, wow, I have six bachelors. Jeez, 15 pairs of blue pants. Wow. Look at all these things that I have.
组织。这就是为什么他们被称为“挑战性无序研究所”。组织。看看，哇，我有六个学士学位。天哪，15条蓝裤子。哇。看看我拥有的所有这些东西。
And then you bring in a coach or a good friend and they have them hold it. Because if they have found if they, if I touch it as. the client, I'm more likely to keep that pair of pants. So the data and the experts say don't touch it. When this first hit the press and there was a Netflix show on all of this, a lot of reporters came to me and said, what do you think? I remember talking to a Japanese reporter who said, what do you think of this expression? And I said, you know, I got to tell you, the first half I told the way, I said, but this is joy. Joy is a deep emotion, right? Listeners, you know, know this as psychology listeners. Joy is not the same as happiness. Happiness is a mood.
然后你找来一位教练或好朋友，让他们拿着东西。因为他们发现，如果作为客户的我亲自去触碰它，我就更有可能留下那条裤子。所以数据和专家都建议不要去触碰它。当这件事最初见诸报端，并且有一档Netflix节目专门讨论这些时，很多记者来找我，问我的看法。我记得曾与一位日本记者交谈，他问我如何看待这个表达。我说，你知道，我得告诉你，前半部分我认同，我说，但这可是“喜悦”（joy）。喜悦是一种深层的情感，对吧？听众朋友们，作为心理学听众，你们知道这一点。喜悦与快乐（happiness）是不一样的。快乐是一种情绪。
Emotions are deeper. You know, we sing every Christmas joy to the world, not happiness to the world. All right. So there's something more to it there. And the Japanese report said, you know, you're right. In Japanese, the word is happiness. It's been translated to joy because joy sells books. So I got issues with this expression. Don't touch it, all right? If it gives you momentary happiness, okay, but keep what gives you joy. What's deep? You don't need 18 snow globes.
情感更为深沉。你知道，我们每年圣诞节都会唱“普世欢腾”（Joy to the World），而不是“普世快乐”。所以，这其中还有更深层的含义。那位日本记者说，你说得对。在日语中，那个词是“快乐”。它被翻译成“喜悦”，因为喜悦能卖书。所以我对这个表达有异议。不要去触碰它，好吗？如果它能给你带来片刻的快乐，那没问题，但要保留那些能给你带来“喜悦”的东西。什么是深层的？你不需要18个雪花球。
Maybe you can get away with four, three, you know, less. You don't need every piece of artwork your kids did for you. Maybe you could pick up the key one of each age or something like that, you know? Again, no one's saying live like a pauper. You know, the Hindu monks, monks spend seven years getting rid of everything they own, except for two robes, two bowls and two spoons. Try going on a cruise with just that. It's impossible.
也许你可以只留四个、三个，你知道，少一点。你不需要保留孩子们为你做的每一件艺术品。也许你可以挑选每个年龄段最关键的一件，诸如此类。再说一次，没人说要像乞丐一样生活。你知道，印度僧侣花七年时间处理掉他们拥有的一切，只留下两件长袍、两个碗和两把勺子。试着只带这些去游轮旅行，那是不可能的。
All right, we keep too much. But we're in this consumer society. Buy, buy, buy. More, more, more. Got to have the latest. Got to have the newest. What's happened is we've made our wants needs. We've made what we want to have as.
好吧，我们留下的东西太多了。但我们身处这个消费社会。买、买、买。更多、更多、更多。必须拥有最新的。必须拥有最新的。发生的情况是，我们把“想要”变成了“需要”。我们把我们想要拥有的东西变成了……
You've got to have. It's a need. And if you don't have it, oh, you're not, you know, you're not fine. You're not perfect. Let me switch to digital clutter, because I know that's something that you've started studying. And so these files and documents and photos and emails that we all have clogging up our computers and our cloud drives, does that kind of clutter affect us the same way emotionally, psychologically as the physical stuff? Currently, we've moved beyond the looking at clutter in the home.
你必须拥有它。这是一种需要。如果你没有它，哦，你就不是，你知道，你就不是好的。你不是完美的。让我转到数字杂物，因为我知道这是你开始研究的东西。那么，我们所有人电脑和云盘里塞满的这些文件、文档、照片和电子邮件，那种杂物在情感和心理上对我们的影响，是否和实物杂物一样呢？目前，我们已经超越了仅仅关注家庭杂物的层面。
We have a number of studies of clutter in the office that we did pre-pandemic, but we published it during the pandemic. One can find those articles. And so then we've moved into now e-waste and digital clutter. So you ask a good question. By e-waste, I mean electronic waste. How many old laptops and cell phones and the old wires that you might have and desktops? On average, there's a Swedish company that found on average people have three cell phones. old cell phones on average that they don't use anymore.
我们在疫情前做过一些关于办公室杂物的研究，但我们在疫情期间发表了它们。人们可以找到这些文章。所以我们现在已经转向了电子垃圾和数字杂物。你问了一个好问题。我所说的电子垃圾是指电子废弃物。你有多少旧笔记本电脑、手机、旧电线和台式机？平均而言，一家瑞典公司发现，人们平均有三部不再使用的旧手机。
So we've started to look at what impact does that happen? Again, as a social community psychologist, I see that relevant to climate and climate control and climate things. How does it impact my community, my setting, my area of living? So we're starting to do that. We have some early pubs. We have data on digital clutter. This is all the electronic email messages that you have, but to be quite honest,
所以我们开始研究这会产生什么影响。同样，作为一名社会社区心理学家，我认为这与气候、气候控制和气候相关事物有关。它如何影响我的社区、我的环境、我的生活区域？所以我们开始做这些研究。我们有一些早期的出版物。我们有关于数字杂物的数据，这就是你拥有的所有电子电子邮件信息，但老实说，
we haven't answered it yet. It's very hard to find doctoral students or even master's who want to study this stuff. So I have more data than I have the ability to analyze at this point. But we're starting to do that. All I can say is, you know, I'm old enough to remember when dot matrix computers were around and those kind of things. And we heard, well, email will save us paper. We won't have to print a paper anymore. Well, then people my generation, you made a hard copy and you still kept it electronically.
我们还没有完全回答这个问题。很难找到想研究这些东西的博士生，甚至是硕士生。所以目前我拥有的数据比我能分析的能力要多。但我们开始着手处理了。我只能说，你知道，我年纪够大，还记得点阵打印机电脑存在的时代，以及诸如此类的事情。我们当时听说，电子邮件会节省纸张。我们再也不用打印纸了。好吧，然后像我这一代人，你制作了硬拷贝，而且你仍然以电子方式保留了它。
You didn't get rid of any of this. And then, because you could see this better, because the font was too small. So we never got rid of stuff. And so now you have all these files. What recommendation? What I give? And this is common sense. Do a triage for a lot of stuff.
你并没有处理掉任何这些东西。而且，因为你可以看得更清楚，因为字体太小了。所以我们从来没有处理掉任何东西。现在你有了所有这些文件。有什么建议吗？我给出的建议是什么？这其实是常识。对很多东西进行分类处理。
You know, in other words, go through your emails and stuff. And look, what do I need? What I need? Don't need it. Don't need it. Don't need it. Don't need it. You know, I have begun to do, I don't do instant messaging.
你知道，换句话说，检查你的电子邮件之类的东西。看看，我需要什么？我需要什么？不需要它。不需要它。不需要它。不需要它。你知道，我已经开始这样做，我不使用即时通讯。
I don't do texting or Snapchat or ticety talk or any of that other stuff. All right. But I will sometimes put my. message in the email address, short little line. So people can see right there. So they don't have to open up the whole thing and they know exactly what I want. And I don't mean just subject line. I mean literally, you know, make sure you call this person, please, something like that. You know, so you want to do some things like that. So we need to be briefer and more succinct, I guess, in some of these things. But yes, we have to learn what's going on. And the question
我不发短信、不用Snapchat、TikTok或任何其他类似的东西。好吧。但我有时会把我的信息写在电子邮件地址里，简短的一行。这样人们一眼就能看到。所以他们不必打开整个邮件，他们就能确切地知道我想要什么。我指的不仅仅是主题行。我的意思是字面上，你知道，确保你给这个人打电话，拜托，诸如此类。你知道，所以你想做一些这样的事情。所以我们需要更简短、更简洁，我想，在这些事情上。但是是的，我们必须了解正在发生什么。而你可能想问的问题是，
you may want to ask is the person with home clutter the same as digital clutter. Great question. Don't know that yet. Is it the same person? If I have one, do I have the other? My gut says yes, but I don't have the data. Well, let me change gears and ask you this one. I don't know if you know the answer to this, but I bet you have an opinion. Is there a generational difference in how people deal with clutter? Because there have been a lot of articles about how baby boomers are trying to downsize and how the millennial Gen Z children don't want their stuff. So do younger people have less clutter as a result of that, or do they just have different clutter? I actually have a high school student who's on my research team, and she's looking at bedtime, a bedroom clutter among high school students.
家里有杂物的人和数字杂物多的人是同一个人吗？好问题。目前还不知道。是同一个人吗？如果我有一种，我会有另一种吗？我的直觉说是，但我没有数据。好吧，让我换个话题问你这个。我不知道你是否知道答案，但我敢打赌你有自己的看法。人们处理杂物的方式是否存在代际差异？因为有很多文章讨论婴儿潮一代如何试图缩小规模，而千禧一代和Z世代的孩子们不想要他们的东西。那么，年轻人因此杂物更少吗，还是他们只是有不同类型的杂物？我实际上有一名高中生在我的研究团队中，她正在研究高中生的卧室杂物。
I'm here in Chicago, and she's in New York. And that's first person ever looking at what do we know about younger people and like teenagers and their clutter. What she has found off the top off, hot off the press, that she'll be presenting at the Eastern Psychological Association Conference, along with my team. in Boston this year, what she found is that they do have clutter. But it's always, see, it's a question of perception, too. To many people, it's not my clutter, it's my stuff. It's important to me.
我在芝加哥，她在纽约。她是第一个研究我们对年轻人和青少年及其杂物了解多少的人。她发现的最新消息，她将与我的团队一起在今年波士顿的东部心理学协会会议上发表，她发现他们确实有杂物。但这总是，你看，这也是一个感知问题。对许多人来说，这不是我的杂物，这是我的东西。它对我来说很重要。
The question is that it's that overabundance. And it's okay to have a lot, as long as it isn't impacting your relationships, your livability space, your finances. You know, let's not demonize people. And I'm not doing that. simply saying, ask yourself, is this in the way? Now, I can share with you, if I may, what my wife does? I have kids in their 30s. And what do we do? Whenever they come to visit,
问题在于那种过剩。拥有很多东西没关系，只要它不影响你的人际关系、居住空间和财务状况。你知道，我们不要妖魔化人们。我没有那样做。只是说，问问自己，这挡路了吗？现在，如果可以的话，我可以和你分享我妻子是怎么做的吗？我有30多岁的孩子。我们怎么做？每当他们回来探望时，
they have to take something from their bedroom back home. Right? Just one thing. Just one thing. They don't visit too often. But anyway, they have to take one thing. The other thing is, when Christmas time comes, all right, she will buy something new for them, of course, but you'll look for something in the house that's gently used, and that's related to that. It's another way. So there's slow ways we can get rid of things, because we have to learn to do that. It's easy to accumulate. Is there generational differences?
他们必须从他们的卧室带走一些东西回家。对吧？就一件。就一件。他们不常回来。但无论如何，他们必须带走一件东西。另一件事是，当圣诞节来临时，好吧，她当然会为他们买新东西，但你会寻找家里一些轻微使用过的东西，这与此相关。这是另一种方式。所以我们可以通过缓慢的方式处理掉东西，因为我们必须学会这样做。积累很容易。存在代际差异吗？
I would suspect probably, because, you know, I have three kids, and my son's the minimalist. But I don't use it in four to six months I get rid of it. His sister's not so much, you know, they probably keep. So I think there is differences. I don't think we can just say it's generation. I think you've got to look at characteristics. You know, what do we know about the person and those backgrounds? Same parents.
我怀疑可能存在，因为，你知道，我有三个孩子，我儿子是极简主义者。如果四到六个月不用，我就把它处理掉。他姐姐就不那么想了，你知道，他们可能会保留。所以我认为确实存在差异。我不认为我们只能说这是代际问题。我认为你必须观察特征。你知道，我们对这个人及其背景了解多少？同样的父母，
And yet one does it one way and one does the other. It's not genetic. So if somebody wants to declutter, they recognize that they maybe are, you know, on the verge of having a problem, but they don't have the wherewithal to bring in a professional. How should they approach getting rid of stuff? Okay. As these experts would say, organize. It's sort it all out and ask you, you know, and see.
然而一个人的做法是一种方式，另一个人的做法是另一种方式。这不是遗传的。所以如果有人想清理杂物，他们意识到他们可能处于有问题的边缘，但他们没有财力请专业人士。他们应该如何处理清理东西的问题？好的。正如这些专家所说，组织起来。把一切都整理好，问问你自己，你知道，看看。
Let's go back to my example, 15 pairs of blue pants. It's a high number, but, you know, so you're looking, you see, wow, I have all these pants. Now, one thing you'll say to yourself is, well, maybe, the hope, you know, hope runs eternal. Maybe it'll come back in style. Well, that pair of pants is from 1981, and you're right, it may come back in style, but you and I know it'll come back a little different. Retailers aren't stupid. They're going to make the product new, retro, but new, you know. So now the cuff might be a little bit different or the collar a little bit different.
让我们回到我的例子，15条蓝色裤子。这是一个很高的数字，但是，你知道，所以你在看，你看到，哇，我有这么多裤子。现在，你会对自己说的一件事是，嗯，也许，希望，你知道，希望永存。也许它会重新流行起来。好吧，那条裤子是1981年的，你说得对，它可能会重新流行，但你和我都清楚，它回来时会有点不同。零售商并不傻。他们会把产品做得新颖、复古，但又是新的，你知道。所以现在袖口可能会有点不同，或者领子可能会有点不同。
So you wear that 1981 thing and they'll know you're from 1981. And you don't want to do that. So don't sell yourself that one. You never know. It might come back. The other thing is, you never know. I might need it again. Yeah, but you don't need 15 of them.
所以你穿上那件1981年的东西，他们就会知道你是1981年的。你不想那样做。所以不要对自己推销那个理由。你永远不知道。它可能会回来。另一件事是，你永远不知道。我可能还需要它。是的，但你不需要15条。
You don't need six spatulas. You can get away with two. for a number of years, I would go around to Catholic parishes, and I would talk about what are we called as Christians to do with stuff? And the title was, A Clutter Ain't Christian, you know, and stuff ain't saintly. And then I would have a decluttering coach from my local area talk about the last half, how to declutter. And they've learned lots of good stuff. That's what she always said, don't go out and buy a box, container box, sort, and put it in. in order and ask yourself, do you need this? And one of the examples she always gave was
你不需要六个抹刀。有两个就够了。多年来，我会去天主教教区，谈论作为基督徒我们应该如何处理物质？标题是，“杂物不是基督徒的”，你知道，东西不是圣洁的。然后我会请我当地的一位清理教练谈谈后半部分，如何清理。他们学到了很多好东西。这就是她总是说的，不要出去买盒子、容器，整理好，然后放进去。按顺序排列，问问自己，你需要这个吗？她总是给出的例子之一是
every Thanksgiving, she needs this particular cookware thing, right? But instead of buying it, she has a friend who happens to have it. And so they rotate it. Maybe another thing you can do is take some item and rotate it around. So you don't want to get rid of it. It's been in your house, but maybe you don't need it that often and somebody else can use it. And so you rotate it around. I mean, we can be clever, we can be creative, we're smart people, we're humans, we can do these things. So again, if you don't know where to begin and you can't afford a coach, that's fine, bring a good friend who will not let you make excuses and will hold you accountable and say, sorry, we got to get rid of a third of these or something like that.
每年感恩节，她都需要这个特定的炊具，对吧？但她没有买，而是有一个碰巧有这个东西的朋友。所以他们轮流使用。也许你可以做的另一件事是拿走一些物品并轮流使用。所以你不想处理掉它。它一直在你家里，但也许你不需要那么频繁地使用它，而别人可以使用它。所以你轮流使用它。我的意思是，我们可以很聪明，我们可以有创造力，我们是聪明的人，我们是人类，我们可以做这些事情。所以再说一次，如果你不知道从哪里开始，又请不起教练，那没关系，带一个好朋友，他不会让你找借口，会让你负责，并说，抱歉，我们得处理掉这些东西的三分之一，诸如此类。
And keep what you want and then ask yourself, do we need to do it? It's tiring, it's exhausting. As we said, it could be an emotional trigger, but we know that the more clutter leads to the to more depression, more mood disorders. As I said earlier, lower psychological well-being, life satisfaction, negative emotions about the self. People with lots of clutter, do lots of self-devaluing the data shows. We didn't do this study, but a study had been done that found it's related to overconsumption of unhealthy foods. So people with lots of clutter tend to eat a lot of maybe junk food more. I know I'm painting a stereotypic image here of the couch potato,
保留你想要的，然后问问自己，我们需要这样做吗？这很累人，很耗神。正如我们所说，它可能是一个情绪触发点，但我们知道杂物越多，越会导致更多的抑郁、更多的情绪障碍。正如我之前所说，较低的心理健康水平、生活满意度、对自我的负面情绪。有很多杂物的人，数据表明他们会进行很多自我贬低。我们没有做这项研究，但有一项研究发现它与不健康食品的过度消费有关。所以杂物多的人往往会吃很多垃圾食品。我知道我在这里描绘了一个沙发土豆的刻板印象，
but look at our culture. Now I can just sit there and with a remote, I'll buy that, I'll buy that, I'll buy that, oh, and you're going to deliver it to me tomorrow in 24 hours. I'll get it. Free shipping. Whoa. Well, of course. You know, we're going to buy more because that is as much effort than it used to be. And so we sit around more, we do less, and lower quality. of life. So there's lots of negative impacts from having clutter. It's not a positive thing. Again, don't be a minimalist. I'm not saying live with nothing. Don't be a Hindu monk. You don't have to do that. But you should be able to live with less and ask yourself why. Do we really need this? Have I been sold to this bill of goods that my life will be better if I have the
但看看我们的文化。现在我可以坐在那里，用遥控器，买那个，买那个，买那个，哦，你明天24小时内就会把它送到我手里。我会得到的。免运费。哇。好吧，当然。你知道，我们会买更多，因为这比以前容易多了。所以我们坐得更多，做得更少，生活质量更低。所以拥有杂物有很多负面影响。这不是一件好事。再说一次，不要成为极简主义者。我不是说一无所有地生活。不要成为印度僧侣。你不必那样做。但你应该能够少拥有一些东西，并问问自己为什么。我们真的需要这个吗？我是否被推销了这种观念，即如果我拥有
newest and the latest phone? I'm going to change gears again and talk about the connection between people who clutter and people who procrastinate. What is that connection? Can you explain how they're related to each other? Okay. I know you've had a recording already, so I don't want to go too much on what procrastination is and is not, but it's not time delay. It's not poor time management. You know, a meta-analysis was done. I'm sure this was covered or your main listeners know what a meta-analysis is. And they found the most effective technique for dealing with procrastination is not time management. In fact, that's the least effective. Cognitive behavior therapy is what works most, CBT, if you're a procrastinator. So it's an interesting link between procrastination and clutter,
最新、最潮的手机，我的生活会更好？我又要换个话题，谈谈那些杂物多的人和拖延症患者之间的联系。这种联系是什么？你能解释一下它们是如何相互关联的吗？好的。我知道你已经录过音了，所以我不想过多讨论拖延症是什么和不是什么，但它不是时间延迟。它不是糟糕的时间管理。你知道，有人做了一项荟萃分析。我相信这已经被涵盖了，或者你的主要听众知道什么是荟萃分析。他们发现处理拖延症最有效的技术不是时间管理。事实上，那是效率最低的。认知行为疗法（CBT）是最有效的，如果你是一个拖延者。所以拖延症和杂物之间的联系很有趣，
and we've published a few studies on that. One form of procrastination is decisional procrastination. That's the cognitive form. Indecision is an interesting strategy that people use, because I did some publications, experimental studies, looking at, is it a cognitive deficit? Is it that people who are indecisive just can't make the decision or is it motivational? And of course, a variety of tasks, it came up motivational. So people choose to be indecisive, all right? But it's a great strategy. Let's take an example. I live in the western suburbs of Chicago outside of Naperville and Aurora, Illinois. Okay. And in Aurora, there's a 31 movie multiplex. 31 movies. Now, imagine you go to the movie with your indecisive friend and you stand there with 31
我们已经发表了一些关于这方面的研究。拖延症的一种形式是决策拖延。那是认知形式。优柔寡断是人们使用的一种有趣的策略，因为我做了一些出版物，实验研究，观察它是一种认知缺陷吗？是优柔寡断的人只是无法做出决定，还是动机问题？当然，在各种任务中，它表现为动机问题。所以人们选择优柔寡断，好吧？但这是一种很好的策略。让我们举个例子。我住在芝加哥西郊，在内珀维尔和奥罗拉之外，伊利诺伊州。好的。在奥罗拉，有一个31个放映厅的电影院。31部电影。现在，想象一下你和优柔寡断的朋友去看电影，你站在那里面对31个
options. What will they tell you? You say, come on, we got to pick a movie and what will they tell you, Kim? I don't know. There are too many for me to choose. Yeah, I know. I know, you say to them, but we got to make a decision. What will they again tell you? Well, what's the next one that's playing? Let's go see that. Oh, that's good. That's decisive. No, the true indecisive will say, well, geez, I don't know. I don't know. They all look good. And then you say, well, I chose last time. And they'll say, well, that's okay. And then you look at your watch and you say, you know, it's 7 o'clock and they're all starting in 10 minutes. Which one? So you make the decision. Now, that's brilliant. Why? Well, when you leave the movie, if the movie was good, both of you say nice. But what if the movie was a stinker? It was a bomb.
选择。他们会告诉你什么？你说，来吧，我们得选一部电影，他们会告诉你什么，金？我不知道。对我来说选择太多了。是的，我知道。我知道，你对他们说，但我们必须做出决定。他们会再次告诉你什么？嗯，下一部放映的是什么？我们去看那部吧。哦，那很好。那是果断的。不，真正优柔寡断的人会说，嗯，天哪，我不知道。我不知道。它们看起来都不错。然后你说，嗯，上次是我选的。他们会说，嗯，那没关系。然后你看了一下手表，你说，你知道，现在是7点，它们都在10分钟后开始。哪一部？所以你做出了决定。现在，这很聪明。为什么？嗯，当你离开电影院时，如果电影很好，你们俩都会说不错。但如果电影很烂呢？它是一颗炸弹。
What will your indecisive friend say to you? Your fault, you chose it. Why did you make me waste that money? Why did you? See, so they never come across bad. All right? They never come across as, you know, a poor decision impacting. So indecision is a very clever strategy that people will use.
你那优柔寡断的朋友会怎么对你说？“是你的错，是你选的。你为什么要让我浪费那笔钱？你为什么要这样？”你看，他们永远不会让自己看起来很糟糕，对吧？他们永远不会表现出自己是一个糟糕决策的影响者。所以，优柔寡断是人们会使用的一种非常聪明的策略。
If I never make the choice, I can never be blamed. Yeah. If I didn't pick the car, it's not my fault. If I didn't choose the dining room table, it's not my fault. I didn't want that refrigerator anyway. The problem is indecisors have to realize that, okay, you have the right not to decide, but if someone else made that decision, I'm from New York, we would say, shut up. You know, we would say, come on, all right?
如果我从不做选择，我就永远不会受到指责。是的。如果我没选那辆车，那不是我的错。如果我没选那张餐桌，那不是我的错。反正我本来就不想要那个冰箱。问题在于，优柔寡断的人必须意识到，好吧，你有权不作决定，但如果别人作了那个决定，我是纽约人，我们会说，闭嘴。你知道，我们会说，得了吧，好吗？
You had the choice, yes, and you chose not to, and you have every right not to make the decision. You let me do it, you empowered me, then you live with it. All right, in terms of clutter, the person who is clutter is very indecisive. And that makes sense. If I don't choose whether it's the keep it or not, okay, and I let somebody else finally say, we're getting rid of it. If in the rare time, it's something, you know, nine months later, I wish we had that. Well, you throw it out, you know, I didn't make that decision.
你当时有选择权，是的，但你选择了不选，你有权不作决定。你让我来做，你授权给我，那你就得接受结果。好吧，就杂物而言，杂乱的人通常非常优柔寡断。这说得通。如果我不选择是否保留某样东西，好吧，我让别人最终说，我们把它扔掉吧。如果九个月后，罕见地出现了某种情况，我希望我们当时留着它。好吧，你把它扔了，你知道，那不是我作的决定。
So you never come across looking bad. So there's lots of relationship. So we've looked at, you know, indecision and clutter. We've looked at in the workplace would impact. People in the office who tend to be more indecisive, who also have more office clutter, just a whole bunch of stuff. We've probably got about 20 pubs, 18, 20 pubs now. But yeah, no, fascinating. I like to go into areas where others haven't done any research. That's why I started in 88, 89 on the first studies on procrastination, some of the first,
所以你永远不会让自己看起来很糟糕。所以这涉及很多关系。我们研究了优柔寡断和杂乱。我们研究了它在工作场所的影响。办公室里那些往往更优柔寡断、办公桌也更杂乱的人，就是一堆东西。我们现在大概有20篇、18到20篇论文了。但是，是的，不，太迷人了。我喜欢进入别人还没有做过任何研究的领域。这就是为什么我在88、89年开始了关于拖延症的第一批研究，这是最早的一些研究，
because there was nothing in the field. Let's see if we can wind up with a question regarding what you're working on now. What are the big questions that you would like to be able to answer? I'm doing more than just looking at clutter myself right now. I have a graduate student, and she's looking at what kinds of resources in communities are there for senior citizens? That's going to be her doctoral dissertation. She's been studying part of community psych. What are the resources?
因为这个领域当时一片空白。让我们看看能不能以一个关于你现在正在研究的问题来结束。你想要回答的重大问题是什么？我现在做的不仅仅是研究杂乱。我有一名研究生，她正在研究社区里有哪些资源是提供给老年人的？这将是她的博士论文。她一直在研究社区心理学的一部分。有哪些资源？
How do we empower people? Another one of my students, who is an international student from Malta, he's looking at, what is the meaning of psychological home, the meaning of home for migrants and immigrants, particularly immigrants. students. You're coming here for a short period of time and you're studying, what does home mean to you? How does it change? What does it impact? Very exciting study that I'm starting to do is in rural healthcare. There's an organization called St. Mary's Clinic that serves people in Kentucky and Tennessee, in Appalachia. And this fall, I was blessed to have the opportunity to go on a trip through a group called Catholic Extension. And so one of the things we saw was this big mobile health clinic that goes around to people
我们如何赋能于人？我的另一名学生，他是来自马耳他的国际学生，他正在研究心理家园的意义，即家对于移民和移居者，特别是移民学生的意义。你来到这里短期居住并学习，家对你意味着什么？它如何改变？它有什么影响？我正在开始做的一项非常令人兴奋的研究是关于农村医疗保健。有一个叫圣玛丽诊所的组织，为肯塔基州和田纳西州阿巴拉契亚地区的人们提供服务。今年秋天，我有幸通过一个叫“天主教推广”的团体参加了一次旅行。所以我们看到的事情之一就是这个大型移动医疗诊所，它在人们周围走动
in Appalachia. You know, I mean, you know the mobile homes that people buy and the sides come out? Well, imagine that where you've got two examining rooms and a pharmacy and offices in there, all this in this mobile unit. And so they'll go and deal with 400 patients that are in rural settings. So I'm looking at as a community psychologist, and I have a doctoral student looking at this, What are the needs of those communities? Let's evaluate the program.
在阿巴拉契亚地区。你知道，我的意思是，你知道人们买的那种移动房屋，侧面可以伸出来吗？好吧，想象一下那个，你有两个检查室、一个药房和里面的办公室，所有这些都在这个移动单元里。所以他们会去处理农村地区的400名病人。所以作为一名社区心理学家，我正在观察，我有一名博士生也在研究这个，这些社区的需求是什么？让我们评估一下这个项目。
I'm trying to get my universities, nursing, and health care professions. I'm in the College of Science and Health involved with doing this. You know, we're in an urban setting in Chicago, but there are rural needs, too. So we're doing assessments of that. I just love all those. There's so many questions that we are out there to ask that improve the quality of life for people. And that's what we need to be doing. So I spent a lot of time early in my career doing work on procrastination, but always did work in community psych, blood donating, litter.
我正在努力让我的大学、护理和医疗保健专业参与进来。我在科学与健康学院，参与做这件事。你知道，我们身处芝加哥的城市环境，但也有农村需求。所以我们正在对此进行评估。我只是喜欢所有这些。我们有太多的问题需要去问，以改善人们的生活质量。而这正是我们需要做的。所以我职业生涯早期花了很多时间研究拖延症，但一直从事社区心理学、献血、乱扔垃圾方面的工作。
I have the only studies to get people to buckle up their children in shopping carts. Buckle up your baby. Yeah, 23,000 kids are heard a year in shopping cart accidents. Then I did, then I had NIH grants looking at a wonderful concept with a colleague called Oxford House for people in recovery from substance abuse and alcoholism. It's a live in 12-step, if you would. No therapist, no training. And yet, we found 85% of the people stay clean and sober two years later. Most treatment programs, you're lucky if you get 10%.
我是唯一做过让人们给购物推车里的孩子系好安全带的研究的人。给你的宝宝系好安全带。是的，每年有23000名儿童在购物推车事故中受伤。然后我做了，然后我获得了美国国立卫生研究院的资助，与一位同事一起研究了一个很棒的概念，叫“牛津之家”，是为那些从药物滥用和酗酒中康复的人准备的。这是一个住家式的12步计划，如果你愿意的话。没有治疗师，没有培训。然而，我们发现85%的人在两年后仍然保持清醒和戒断。大多数治疗项目，你能有10%的成功率就算幸运了。
I did that for 13 years. So lots of questions. I think that's the joy of being an academic. You can ask lots of questions in lots of different areas. And I just ask my colleagues, I love basic research. I'm trained as an experimental social. But also, let's make a difference and leave a legacy and make a, difference in other people's lives. I hope this podcast has done that for your listeners.
我做了13年。所以有很多问题。我认为这就是作为学者的乐趣所在。你可以在许多不同的领域提出许多问题。我只是问我的同事，我喜欢基础研究。我受过实验社会心理学的训练。但同时，让我们有所作为，留下遗产，并在他人的生活中产生影响。我希望这个播客为你的听众做到了这一点。
I hope some people have heard some, among all my ramblings, some kernel of information that they can use to make their life a little bit better. I think you did achieve that. I want to thank you, Dr. Ferrari, for joining me. And it's been a lot of fun and really interesting. So thank you so much. Thank you for having me. It's good to be had. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spinkingofpsychology.org Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion.
我希望有些人听到了，在我所有的闲谈中，听到了一些他们可以用来让生活变得更好一点的信息核心。我想你确实做到了。我要感谢法拉利博士加入我。这非常有趣，也非常有意义。所以非常感谢你。谢谢你邀请我。很高兴能参与。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org、Apple、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condyion。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。